that's kim kardashian freaking out over
an ice bath it's so crazy kim's sister
courtney threw a lavish spa day thanks
to her lifestyle brand pooch and of
course the kardashians documented the
whole thing on instagram
today is our
poolside with push
and
we are doing a spa day a very
intimate group
poolside with push offered hot stone
massages facials and sand baths
[Laughter]
[Music]
complete with an intention tree wait so
what do i do write an intention
oh i have a lot of intentions and the
most extravagant matcha bar
can we get an iced lavender matcha
please
the guest list well besides sister kim
miranda kerr and adrian hoeten joined in
on the fun with adrian devouring all the
vegan food in case you were wondering if
it was good
i'm absolutely going to finish all of
this but while the day was supposed to
be relaxing it was quite the opposite
for kimmy once it was time for some
cairo therapy okay faith in us
adrian has faith do i tip my toes no
if you check it you're not okay guys we
are doing this
[Applause]
and we can only imagine what court is
saying
there's people that are dying anyway kim
wrote on instagram okay so they said
it's mind over matter but i am not sure
i was ready i was the weakest link here
and usually pride myself on being
mentally strong but i hate being cold
but the reality star didn't give up and
gave it a second chance
[Music]
that's when kim opted to be everyone's
hype man and cheered on the other ladies
including adrian who decided to stay in
the longest okay
you are strong i feel like i can
convince myself of anything in my mind
okay
you guys adrian's going for six minutes
we gotta get some of this because she's
knowing this obviously
oh wait this sun glowing on your face
this is a really good look
okay adrian is the only one going for
the six minute club
she's gonna do this this is so good for
her you got this
the pooch party comes days after kim
posted on instagram that filming has
started on the kardashian family's new
hulu show it's always so much fun
on thursday the 40 year old reality star
shared a photo showing a microphone pack
on her lap kim captioned the photo day
one indicating that production has just
begun
so cool and while we don't know what the
new reality show entails will be keeping
up with the kardashians on their social
media
[Music]
you